yo sup I buy his little yatta here with
BuzzFeed and right now I'm about to be
talking about some my first time first
time meeting Kanye West when I like
finally met him like when the exact
conversation was he invited me to a
studio in LA and common was there he had
invited me and then he was there for
like five minutes and laughs sounds like
very Kanye like first time you realized
you wanted to pursue a music career
oh I figure question so I used to play
around and make like parodies and those
food and stuff but really doors % was on
I was in college when dad just I had
just came back from being arrested I got
arrested in Florida
so then cause I was in history class or
social studies or whatever and I just
moved been in that class Delites law and
my laptop open and a teacher was talking
and just I'm like I can't do this I got
some music you know like believing
myself chopped out they test it over
here first level you ever met
Ludacris or some good that I met like
other kids
absolutely I met as I said I be probably
be rocky but I start liking in common
take me to his house now tell him I was
a graphic designer
really I was a rapper and he turns
around he was on his competing turned
around
hold up I could this way that in my
house I'm just like you know the old mr.
graphic design I was telling you about
yeah he's but he has some graphic
designs he wants to show you it I have
I'm you myself would be much my doubts
which defendants if I kinda wish I was
the first one I bought my own way the
first one I ever got was criss cross
when Cosette I was a child but to
inspire my hair and like a lot of my
Styles clothing I stood to all day all
night
first job our first job I worked at
McDonald's I was 14 or 15 thankful I
should know that first caught my first
car was a g-wagon Mercedes because my
mom wouldn't bomb in a car so when I
first saw my dua I was jogging her car
she had a BMW she drive it all the time
then I bought her BMW I paid it off she
had like a cardinal I paid it off so
then I had that car then I bought it G
Wagen so my first car was the G Wagen
first time someone recognized in person
I don't know but I do remember a really
good friend named said I'm I'm inside
went into Linux so one day I'm walking
in and they ain't gonna be able to move
I was with it he said first Instagram
folks I remember my dad made me use to
come by 2013 my dad had one I remember
with sending five guys this is so weird
I know this I had a red bands I don't
wanna take a picture and show me it's
like show me oh I'm gonna ice and how
you get these filters it's grant filters
ticket vacuuming showing up it says post
in it first nice turnaround clothes
first music inspiration like I say
crisscross definitely as far as style
their hair just so I deftly cuz fast
I don't think I've ever said that but
yeah first song or rap you ever wrote
was a song called bittersweet it still
[ __ ] up what you do under our D the
real song how'd you sneak parodies but
this was like the price of real song I
had everything scoff bitter and I did a
video and my my my career one my mom was
going out all my friends over I was
wearing her clothes I had took the
ladder and climbed on the roof now all
owner weakness good a sweet that's what
is for first embarrassing moment on
stage
I really wanted to embarrass like I
forget Leah called Tom I forgot that
yeah well you know I'm just really goofy
so you know our brilliant barbers bring
us a moment I had a show in LA and I
brought out 21 Savage so he came out I'm
a DJ oh my did you shoot off my oldie
did you do stupid add it up so I brought
him out about some stuff and he plays
the chopping screw Bergeon it's been
extra slow it was like chopping and so
anyone was like trying to do it and then
someone managed it was about to beat up
my DJ and 21 was by the throat amazing
my DJ I was that wasn't because I was
about to knock him I was like truly like
like red cheeks and bears like what is
happening I was crazy
I never told I'm sorry first edible
experience I have got in LA with a group
of friends I think we went to a smoke
shop but I was young I was like 16
something and I couldn't get in here but
they had like samples like edible
samples and I think I had a really small
rice krispies treat just remember like
getting really stuck I don't think I
ever did it again after that price very
that comes to mind from the south to
first memory I can remember we get the
table reading beats the unclassified Tom
everything
and you could clearly tell because like
like everyone's like in character and he
was just kind of like reading it like an
essay but then when we came for set he
had totally had it ready it was just
funny because they were a bit like I
haven't trying extra hard but obviously
disease don't weigh more things and I
can worth the Mesa
I had them super prepping for the skip
and then he was like it was like nothing
else make sure you check out my new
movie I'll hide to come in for 21 m2e I
should get extremely high watch it
showing extremely high